okay so since the designated uh
announcer has
um
has disappeared
i have the pleasure of um introducing
christian achenmeier for the second part
of his lecture writing down polynomials
via representation theory
thank you very much
so this
last time was about representation
theory and we will now connect these two
polynomials
and how to write these polynomials down
so
remember we have the symmetric group
acting a lot what's the symmetric group
on the letters
um so
we have a right action and um when we
see in these we've seen these things um
a lot i think during the last few days
so we have a right action of the
symmetric group on d ladders
on the and now i want to have the tensor
power it should be the d tensor power
of some vector space and i want to call
it w star and it has a star because i
want to think of these vector spaces
having row vectors
and how does it work
it's just
oh i want to have a right action because
it's
it's just nicer to have a row i have a
right action
so it's um
so i write
pi here
and this is a circle which which which
is my action symbol here
and it will also mean other things i
will we will use this circle for all
kinds of things
so this
works nicely as this
oh um yeah
of the symmetric group yes
so that's our right action
and there's an invariant subspace that
we are interested in which are the
polynomials basically
and i want to talk about that for a
second
there's an invariant subspace it's
called
sim d
w star
which is
the set of invariants it's the subspace
of invariance
so and the point of this subspace is
in our case that this is actually these
are actually polynomials so you have an
those symmetric tensors here
um so those are yeah so those symmetric
tensors are actually putting over it so
if you have an f
and some d w star
then this corresponds
to a homogeneous
polynomial
of dvd
in
dim w star
variables
and how does it work so say you have
that your f and you want to evaluate it
some
say
v
or say let me call it h sorry let me
call it h evaluated some h
then um how is it defined
you can define polynomial evaluation now
which is just saying you have your
tensor it's a
it's a row tensor
and you do tensor contraction
with its with a d tensor power of
of h
so this is now transfer contraction
right so this is a this is just
basically only a this is a row vector
that's a column vector it's just
contraction
let me give you an example of this
because this is our main correspondence
between polynomials and tensors and
from then on we will only be concerned
with tensors
and and how to construct these symmetric
tensors so once we've settled this
projection here um we can move on so
example
so we take
say x
it's our
vector 0 1
and y is our vector y z uh
1 x is 1 0 y is 0 1
basis
of
c 2 star
so those are the just in c2 but this
dual space so as row vectors
just c2 but as row vectors and our f
should be x squared y
that's our polynomial
and that h be the column vector 2 3
what happens when we evaluate
so if you evaluate x squared y
add 2 3
that's
well that's 12 right
um and
well this other interpretation as a
symmetric tensor is the same thing
you can write it as 1 over 3 12 plus 12
plus 12 and why is that so why why do i
do this because i want to show you that
this is actually the same thing
so this tensor is
x tends to x tends to y
plus
x times a y
tends to x
plus y tensor x tends to x
so that's the symmetric tensor
x squared y
and we contract this one
well 2 3 to the third power here
yes
so this is the same thing as saying it's
just saying well this is x squared y
contracted with 2 3 to the third power
well this is how i want to make this um
oh i mean this is how i want to think of
polynomials which i just want to think
of these polynomials as these symmetric
tensors here
okay and then you can evaluate by just
evaluation is a contraction of tensors
with a power
and that this will be important so
evaluation is always a contraction with
a power
is a we start with a polynomial and
well i mean this is a tensor also i mean
this is yeah but that's exactly the cost
well i wanted i want to show that if i
write the correspondence from this one
is the following tensor
this is just this is if you take okay
this is the tensor
this is the symmetric tension
corresponding to it
and i want to show
i want to show that evaluating it
is the same in terms of construction
so the correspondence is this one
when you um
so the correspondence is this one you
you write it out
as just um as the symmetric tensor word
and then the
what what there is to prove is actually
that evaluation is nothing else than the
tensor contraction which basically
follows from the definition of what the
evaluation is so you look carefully at
what is actually polynomial evaluation
and then you see that this is actually
the same thing
so
yeah so
and you can you can actually even
construct f and all its monomials if you
want to actually do that then you can
also also also do that
if you want to do that
okay so the correspondence is just this
is written as x times x times y is the
symmetric tensor
is this tensor here
is the that's that's the example and
hopefully you should clear from that
example how to do this chaos one is so
there's a formal correspondence
is evaluation available of a putting
over at a point
okay and there's a note
we have that
if
so we get this projection of tensors so
say capital p is the projection
from our tensors
to symmetric tensors
then
and written also on the right written
from the right
on the right is always because this is
functions so i write it from the right
so then we have
then this evaluation so if you have your
f and you project it say f is
so you take your f you project it and
then you contract it with some
the tensor power
and this is the same it's just
contracting f
and
well that's clear but
um even
and that's the point
even if f itself
was not already symmetric
but only some some tensor
so
you can write down polynomials now much
easier
because you don't have to actually take
care of
the fact that your
um
that your vector that you write down
is a symmetric tensor you can do this
with any tensor
um what is the reason that h is
symmetric yes the reason oh yeah the
reason for this equality let me just
quickly state this the reason is that
you can put brackets here and since h is
already symmetric um this projection
basically does nothing
and and you're done here so you can
always do that even if your f is just
some normal tensor
and and i will construct these kind of
tensors okay
and you can interpret them as
polynomials you can evaluate them it's
already fine and we would have
polynomials
it's worth remarking that you know
although this looks like a silly trick
you were able to do to evaluate
polynomials that other people could not
come close to evaluating one okay you
know i mean this is really about that
that's what we do when you evaluate this
in a sense you just pick one of the
tensors and use that to evaluate it
but when you're doing it by binomials
that's what you do yes
i mean we will come to results later i
mean just but you know but it's good to
shadow okay it's okay it's very useful
to see these things like that
it saves a lot of computational time if
you do it like this so reminder
the main things we are interested in are
um
are these so that n
and this is the padded permanent
those are the ones that we are actually
interested in and those are in sum w
and w is actually the symmetric power
of c n squared so that's what we're
actually interested in
and
and this was defined as the invariant
space
right it was defined as this we just
defined it
as the invariant space
um or over sn in this case
so actually
um so a w has a more complicated
structure than it was actually then it
would then as it would seem
so actually what we're interested in is
we're interested in these ones
so you have a sim d of sim n
and then you have a cn squared
star
and this one
us let is have a look at what this one
is it's a bit
and a bit of animation so this is the dm
tensor power of c n squared dual
and now well what should you do what do
you do
i mean this is basically raising raising
this space you to the tens of power and
taking its invariance right because how
you get the symmetric power you raise it
to the tensor power and take its
invariance so you take the space here
raise it to the
power and take its invariance so you
have this space
you raise it to the power so it means
you get
um these s n cross s n cross and so on
because there's n in variance
and then you take the invariance again
so this is looks complicated
and the nice thing is
that we actually know already
a lot about these things here but we
don't know a lot about the sd invariants
this is related to the tumblr homework
where you actually knew a lot about the
semi-center tables but then you had to
take invariance it was not completely
clear what was going on this would be
exactly this
okay but let me try to do actually this
connection
so
um
so our w is some
call it
for a moment
let's let me
oh no it's fine we don't have to have
that
we just take some space w we want to
know now what is a what is the geo
representation of it
so we have an action
of our test of space by a gl as well
we go to v
capital d
so
capital d will basically be d times n
this will basically be
our main example
so you want to act on it with some g
and g is some element from
g l w i'll say
c w
and well this is just the right
direction and we all know how this is
defined just the normal action that you
would have so it's g v one gb2
and so on
and so gvd
okay and and we see immediately that
both actions actually commute so um
because this is only doing yeah so one
is rearranging the tensor factors where
one is completely doing the same on each
factor so um
so those commute which is nice
and now what is the highest late vector
and those are actually the ones that we
are interested in
so we will construct these
we will not be so much concerned
i mean it just skips after the chart and
lower i it would be fine all right
okay
christian yes uh since the temptation
isn't hard for me to parse can you like
kind of tell me where the lecture is
going so i can like try to focus on
what's important for me
oh yeah the lecture is going to the we
are now constructing highest rate
vectors which are the um in inside
tensor inside this space here
and highest wave vectors will be the
ones that we actually then take the um
project to the invariant spaces so those
will be polynomials and for those we can
actually we can um
see how to evaluate those the highest
languages have the important property
that they actually characterize the
representation theory of the whole um
of the whole vector space here so so
that you'll actually be constructing
these things and advise yes
they would be actually contracted at the
end i mean if i yeah well i mean they
they the points to actually contract
them at the end yes
and
nice results actually so so we can
actually express some results of some
papers actually in that language let's
contract them and see what happens and
and um
so those are not difficult if you just
see what happens when you consider just
taking it a step further back if you're
looking for
you're looking for useful equations in
this gigantic space of polynomials on
polynomials right so representation
theory splits this up into small pieces
and he's saying you only have to check
one vector in each of these subspaces
and then he's going to give you a recipe
for how to check that vector without
even explicitly writing it and we never
write because if you write it it'd be
just gigantic
well i mean
different problems to evaluating at
different points if you're doing just
technology unless you
pick specific points that help you to
evaluate it you can pick generic points
you can you can also of course in this
case you would want to evaluate it
actually at the determinant and right
for example
problem you take some highest weight
vector yes
and you want to check whether it
vanishes not at the perimeter
yes you want to you want to contract it
with a tensor power of the determinant
tensor
take the per determinant cut it
permanent tensor you take the permanent
tensor you contract it and then you want
to check if it's non-zero much faster
meaning
and you are saying that you don't do it
in an obvious way but in some other way
which makes it fast right
it's faster apparently but um we don't
we haven't analyzed its complexity it
also gives you theoretical results too
and it's it's it's very fast awesome
yeah it's like it's much better than
white i mean
complexity theory
i mean we did not study it the
complexity of the
just it just gives you for the small
examples it's good
and it gives actually so for example
there's a paper like kardashian
landscape weight and the result you can
immediately get it from this if you see
it as a contraction then it is an
application of the pigeonhole principle
and you see that and we get basically
the result of that paper and you can see
it like that which is really good
because the result itself is really
really good and tells us a lot about the
partitions right so this is very helpful
so and i yeah so highest rate request
and and we know that highest rate
because our sufficient as obstructions
so we want to construct exactly those
vectors those are the ones that if you
want to study things with
representational theory it should be
highest like vectors so i want to define
now what that is because those are the
important vectors that are going to look
at
so there is the
un sitting inside of gln
and let's just let this be just the
group of
upper triangular
matrices once on the main diagonal
so also the maximal unit protein group
and then there's a torah sitting inside
which is
which is this one just having
um yeah this is the top side like the
diagonal matrices
so now um
first let's define what a weight vector
is
so you have um
f in some representation
say b star is a representation
and then
a weight vector
satisfies
just that it's scaled by the action it
says that for all
and now you have t1 d2 up to tn
within the taurus
that your f if you act
on it with the torus
it is just scaled so this f is actually
is
well i didn't want to wait for what it
is actually
it is the following
it's
those are just scale ups right just
um complex numbers
and your f if you act on it
with a diagonal matrix that gets scaled
and these are the scaling factors that
it picks up
that's the weight vector of weight
of weight lambda
and lambda is actually well those are
just if this is a polynomial
representation then those are natural
numbers
so this pair it's just some um
set of natural numbers and both
giveaways are skating
that's a weight vector and now um the
highest wave vector
well then you can put inverses here
i mean uh you can also replace it with
disease here so it's up to a sign this
is correct okay
i have to assign this certainly correct
so weight vector
f
in this representation
will that satisfies another constraint
it satisfies for all group elements
in the unitary group
a unique portion too
it satisfies that
actually or if you take your
time store and you act like what these
upper triangular matrices you get your
tensor back
and if you have that it is called a high
strain vector
and this looks a bit uh
this comes from representation theory
and you can prove
that
this basically defines
your representations
so um every irreducible geo
representation has exactly a single
highest weight vector so if you are
interested in the representations that
occur
you look at the highest rate vectors
because there we
the dimension of the highest vector
space is exactly
how often your irreducible occurs in
your decomposition
okay so let's
also isolate vectors
so h w v of lambda
of some representation
it denotes
the
subspace
of highest laid back doors
halfway
lambda so it turns out that lambda is
actually always a
partition let me give you an example
an important one that we will need
of a highest rate vector in our space
because this is a bit complicated
definition of course let me give you an
example
so the example is d sub i
which stands for determinant
and we want to have the following vector
it's e1 where g2
where g3
r2pi
and this should be a vector
and
and as as always this is correct uh
up to
left and right action if i did it wrong
then
i apologize so this is the electorate
and this is the highest late victory
well this is a highest electron
of weight
well its weight is easy to determine
because you act on it with a um
with a
torus element which is diagonal matrices
and it's and the e1 this case
um well to the power one there's only
one e1 there's only one e2 so this is
all just by the
so lambda one is one lambda two is one
so this the weight is actually one one
one and so on
one and then zeros
and this is i times
and this
a height is right vector it's a building
block of uh of a highest weight vector
in your intensive space
don't you have to prove it
don't you have to prove it but it's
environment and yes yes yes you can do
that so yes of course you have to prove
everything so
so
it works as follows if you have say you
have
an upper triangular matrix so say you
have some entry here
then basically that you um you change
some e3 for example to e3 plus e2
and then you expand this thing and you
get an e2 where g2 which cancels
so this one i just basically generally
is
right so this is this is a high subject
yes well that's of course yeah so we
proved that
and it has a computational aspect
so um when you contract this tensor so
this is why it's called a determinant
if you take this and contract it
so you have sorry this is a conduction
symbol here
so you take a di
and you contract it with some tensor y1
y2
up to some y i
then what is that
so and the yj say let's take them from
c to the n
so what is that this is um
if you contract this gives you a
determinant
of an i by i matrix and this is now the
crucial point is
this is you take your vectors y
one up to y i
and basically just take a random in a
matrix so they will have columns i
columns but they still have n rows when
you only take the upper eye
rows gives you a square matrix and you
take its determinant this is exactly
what this contraction is well this is a
determinant because if you contract with
such a tensor you better determine it
so this is a determinant
yes so this
is
the determinant
of the
i times i matrix
where the j cut where the
j column
is
the first
i entries
of yj
okay so get this square matrix
and then
you can use this as a building block for
more advanced size like the course
and we basically get every high speed
vector in this way so this is a
construction that is in a sense a
canonical construction we have to we
check we of course we chose the basis
but i mean we can we can show that
this construction is basically the only
construction varies for isolated groups
what you can do is
so the important example
so that lambda will be a partition
and now with capital d boxes
and column length
the color length should be theta
up to
theta j maybe
and
the vector
and i want to call it lambda
um
yeah it's lambda hat
is defined as the tensor product
of these
determinants here
so it's over you take every column
and you contract and you cancel them up
so the vector this vector is the highest
weight vector
of weight down there
and the proof is the same
as the proof of this high-strength
vector
because
you get i mean you let the torus act and
you know all the tones acts on the
single factors
so that gives you the correct weight and
then the un invariants you also get
because all the single factors are you
an invariant so
one is also a highest rate vector and
has the correct weight
so um
okay so um
since the actions commute
the actions of the um
general linear group here and the
symmetrical those commune
so whenever something is the highest
rate vector see this was only defined of
course using notions of glm so you can
now also apply permutations from the
symmetric group on d ladders and you
still get the highest rate vector
so this is because of the actions
commute
this is not corresponding to the reduced
representation right it would they will
correspond to it what corresponds to
evidence or
oh let me say that actually let me say
that maybe
um
i can i can tell you that also of course
that's um
so every
irreducible
gln representation
contains
up to scale of course
exactly one highest rate vector
okay and
so
if
if its weight is lambda
we call it we call it
the representation
lambda in these curly brackets
and um
yeah so in particular
we see that
and this of course that all requires
proof of force in particular we see that
the highest rate vector space
for the white lambda of lambda
is one dimensional
and we see that the highest rate vector
space
of mu
lambda is let's see what dimensional
right so that's zero
because it has only a single one if the
weight is correct this only latches
so you get more highest rate vectors
when just applying
um elements of the somatic tube
to the size weight vector so you have
more
and we want to add more we won't have
all the highest electrics that you can
get
so that's what you do
so the edge is commute so
what we have is not only that ahead of
the highest predictor but also number
head
if you apply pi is the highest making
tool
and this and
the next section tells you that these
are actually all the highest likelihoods
there are no more highly straight
vectors
and this is called show y value
tells you that there are this is
actually an exhaustive list
of make vectors if you take advantage of
your combinations of them well in your
combinations is of course allowed
so um the theorem is the following
and it's this this is the most important
theorem which actually draws the
connection between the
general linear group and the semantic
group in these spaces
so it's um
it's this one the tensor power of c and
star how does decompose
it decomposes
over lambda
into tensor products
which are the inducible geo
representations tens of the irreducible
asset representations
this is how it decomposes and um and
those lambda those are
um well well done very similar petitions
with
capital d boxes
and
at most
n rows
okay and um that's that's a very
interesting correspondence but we can
make it very precise we can make it much
precise much more precise as so we
already see from the last lecture we
know exactly how this space looks like
and we remember this is the reducible
s d representations here
and we have
we know that the basis here is given by
standard tables so we can make this very
explicit here
so we had a highest rate vector here
which was lambda hat
where uh how does it correspond to some
highest electric look here
and um it works as follows
so the high z vector then the head
on the left hand side
corresponds
to
on the right hand side this is the
following so you first get this there's
only one highest rate vector here
so that's that's clear so it should be
isolated to lambda of lambda
but now you have some tableau here
and let me just do this in one example
so it's called the column standard table
so let's just do some example here
otherwise notation gets messy
and this is column standard
column standard
this is this will be the um the highest
vector corresponds to the i mean you
know how to fill it right you just fill
in the column what column you get
instead of tableau
okay this is this one
um
yeah
so
in particular
um if we have this strong correspondence
here the two wide variety we can now
have a look at the highest level vector
space here in this space of course
and this is what because we are
interested in isolate pictures here
let's just do that
so um oh let me just start here
so we look at the highest rate vector
space in that space to consider some
partition mu
i want to look at the highest rate
vector space well
there um
if you take the highest vector space of
this large sum
there is not much that actually survives
because there is only actually one
summon that survives
so high side nectaris
regarding to which representation
they don't have that
so um okay hi is
of this space
well what is it it's the highest vector
space of the whole sum
so you can
draw this into the sum
and we know already how this looks like
this is exactly only this one
dimensional thing here so all the i mean
this is zero dimensional very very often
but in one case
where it is one dimensional
it's this one so highest rate vectors
here correspond exactly
to well this is one dimensional so this
is exactly the sd
representation so as as d
representations these two these two
spaces are the same those are isomorphic
sd representations so all the
representation of u is actually only
going on in these tuples so you can you
can actually do all the things with
well without thinking of polynomials you
can do everything there's the temples
okay so
this is of course
very very nice so we know um so these uh
d times in
so let's let's get started and say these
d terms in
and observe
that
actually the d tensor power
of c n star
is the d tensor power
of the m tensorflow of c and start
or just
divide it into two
and um
and now we do these
projections so
we project down here
to the tensor power
of the of also to the symmetric power
now
and now the first interesting thing
happens and it's related to your
homework assignment
so
um well we know that these are the
standard tables so the basis here of the
highest rate vector space
is given by standard tempos let me make
this more precise let me just write
highest grade vector spaces here
everywhere
this is the highest electric space it
projects of course to a high so you like
this space
so now what happens is a basis here is
given by standard term blues you project
it down basis here is given by the semi
standard tables with rectangular content
and you see that by seeing well what
happens here is um that actually you
have in your tableaus numbers one up to
d times n
so what happens is you identify the
first n numbers in your tableau and they
just become a one and then the second
and numbers just become a two and then
another the further numbers they become
three and so on so you have um
you have d num well you have n numbers
so the numbers comes that comes in
blocks of n
so this is bases given by standard
doubles
and the relations are exactly the grass
and blue correlations they they of
course still
stay the same right so this is standard
top rules
and now here's the basis
given
by semester tables
with content
and it was nn right
and not only that i mean
it's very it's not
very it's not only theoretical it's very
explicit you can write on you can
basically do these contractions
yes you explained this to me once and i
think
i can do an example one example yeah
sure i will do an example of this of how
to project a standard table to a
semester law
listen yeah
it's c
to the n and it's i just put a star
because i think of row vectors what is
it
c to the n
is the
is the c to the n is is the
there's a little end and
is the a big
degree the bigger is dimensional you can
think of you can think of if you want to
you can think of this as n squared if
you want to because this is the number
of variables we are interested in for
the determinant so if you want to you
can you can think of capital n squared
but if you can also enlarge it it's just
some big number
this is a as large as you want it to
make these statements too
if you if you have d it's fine aren't
you
yeah okay
i want to give an example of this
projection
so you have if you have one two
three four
this projects
to what you take this block what this
these are the first numbers those are
the second numbers so this projects to
this
oh well this was in this was a s4 and
this is now
if you project to
the
second power of sim 2 then this is this
projection and if you would have started
with that tableau
this would go to one one two two which
we had last time is actually zero so
that one vanishes under this projection
this one does not avenge it stays here
it's the basis vector
okay so that works and now
i see so so so the of the ones that are
non-zero they're pre-images of the
standardization of them
the it the pre-image is
the standardization that's it it's i
mean if you start with a standard table
yeah if you haven't seen it but there's
a standard way to go from a
semi-standard template to a standard
catalog called the standardization okay
so i guess that's what this is well i
guess don't i'm not familiar with that
concept
just you put in basically you have these
blocks you put in numbers one up to n
and then it takes the next block through
the number is what n plus one and so on
i mean the comic books people you
you see a string of equivalent numbers
the ones for the right are larger and
again that breaks ties and that gives
you a standard capital
that's called the standardization i
think that's there's not much going on
yeah it's an app okay
and there's no sophisticated no no
judith you know what
you can immediately write the numbers in
it's not nothing is happening
so of course the most important thing
now is if we are
at this point we want to
somehow
um evaluate these things because now
this is the most um interesting thing is
now we have these semi-standards of laws
somehow
and we know we we don't have to take
care of this symmetrization right we
don't because we know uh we saw in the
beginning that this is it's uh
superfluous to take care of that
symmetrization we can just contract
right we don't have to project it here
so basically we are done here
we just want to know how to if we write
down a semi-center tableau how to how to
do this contraction now so what is this
and it can be interpreted
combinatorially
this the semicircle actually now defines
a polynomial you write it down it's the
polynomial
projection of course but you don't have
to project
so now um
well evaluating
is now this contraction you have a
lambda head
you have your pi acting on it which is
basically place giving your
semi-standard table and you want to sum
up contract with some tensor y
you raise it to the d power
and y
is an element of sim n
c capital
so so i'm just getting confused so in
the case of permanent verses yes your y
is determinant for example
why is your determinant here it is
sitting there or not it is sitting in uh
inside this space here you're sitting
inside this space i think it would be
simply there right
answers of c n squared which is time d
right it would be placing the operator
isn't it this is yes but this is not the
sim yet i mean because we don't have to
you could you could do that you could
project even further yeah and there
would be some d reasons
well the determinant itself is of course
but the highest is there yes but we
don't have to actually do that because
the contraction takes care of that so if
you contract the stencil with that
tensor you don't you can throw out you
can throw out actually this
symmetrization in between
but yes you're right the highest ratio
itself is the image under that
projection and you are not going your
point is you are not going to do
evaluation there is it
i am contracting this tensor i'm
contracting the tensor here or that
tensor over there which automatically
projects the tensor because you can if
you have this
you can squeeze in between a projection
operator if you want to
and then this is your this is your
highest rate vector now
but since this is already
um symmetric
this projection operator actually does
nothing so you can strike it out you
don't have to have the projection so you
can actually work with the ones that are
not projected
this is actually very very helpful i
mean because we know what we can write
on all semi-standard templates quite
easily
only problem is that if you do
symmetrization you won't have a basis
anymore yeah you don't have a basis
anymore this is the basis
yeah it gets really complicated we know
that from a nice lecture it gets really
complicated and you don't know actually
what's going on because the dimension of
that space here that you get when you go
to sim here is um
is the platform coefficient
so you don't know
much right we know from last texture
that's a big problem so the point is you
don't need to know the decomposition
yeah you don't you don't need to know
the difference i'm just trying to
understand yes you don't need to know
the decomposition
projects for you i guess that's the
point the valuation does the projection
without you yes evaluation does the
projection for you guess
this is free lunch it is it's realistic
i don't like this it's a d factorial
freelancer that you get yes
so
okay so
now what you want to do is now evaluate
this thing
and there's a pictorial interpretation
actually of that so what you want to do
is let me give you a pictorial way of
actually doing this evaluation it's a
tense of contraction and if you go
through the definitions of lambda hat
and pi
then you get the following combinatorial
interpretation of what actually happens
when you have such a tableau and you
want to evaluate it
so this is your top rule say this first
of all
then you evaluate it at
a times b say say a times b yes that's
as symmetric tensor
and um
well
what happens is
um
i mean the number of variables is
exactly
the um the block size right and what
happens is you put
in your trouble your
vector a b in each block so that's a b
here that's a b here that's a b here
take this and then you sum over it and
you have to you have to put it in all
kinds of different ways because this
gets quite messy if you expand this it
gets really messy and then you have a
lot of summons but that's what you get
so you put your
into your blocks you put all your things
and it will get messy so there will be
more and more
but
in every block
right in every block
you have exactly a b and an a that's the
requirement
because ba is where you want to evaluate
and then well what are those numbers
those numbers are now
these uh the contraction of these
these d i's here which are determinants
so the co so each of these summons
is exactly one determinant so it's the
determinant
of um a b here
and that's the determinant of b b which
is so this one has actually zero let me
let me yeah this is zero so let's
determine of some a column
or which is which has only two entries
sorry so there's
a b
times determinant b b which is zero
times well times the first entry of a
times the first entry of a
and that one here is determinant
and it has
comes b b
is times the a b
times
a1 a1 right
and and so on so you summarize those
yep can answer so i just sure yeah so
instead of evaluating the projected
thing as permanent you are going to
evaluate the unprojected thing at what
what at the permanent
raise to a power raised to a power so
make you raise it to a power so you make
it symmetric so this one is actually
symmetric if you take the permanent and
raise it to the leaf power it's
symmetric under nrsd yeah so you erase
it it is symmetric already so if you
contract a non-symmetric tensor and a
symmetric tensor it's the same as first
symmetrizing the tensor and
then so you get something like like this
and
which is very i mean i will show you get
i will show you now this actually works
in practice
yeah if you yes
yeah i can show you so there is a
theorem
there's a scottish language there
and of course the language is different
there
and this
what is my interpretation of it so you
um
you want to contract now say you have a
tableau
if lambda
has a first row
longer
shorter so shorter
then
n minus m times d
all highest rate vectors
of
weight lambda
vanish
on
well let me call it
z to the n minus m
times some h
where h is in
see this follows
hold us now because what you do is you
write down your tableau
say you have a so you have a short
first row
and then you have some other stuff here
and now what happens is if you evaluate
at this h
at this and this that's important
so this tensor
has the important property that if you
expand it as if you write it as a tensor
then
it has
n
minus m
factors
that are z
right
that are exactly z
right it's n minus n factors and now
well whatever your block arrangement
here is doesn't really matter how you
arrange your blocks here
um
every block
so in your in the evaluation
will receive
well it receives n minus m
entries z
so now what happens
um is the following so in total
since in total this whole um each
summoned has d times n minus m entries z
so in total
every summoned
and at summit i mean i mean something
like this that's a summit here
it has a's and b's and we've seen
already something like this happens
quite well if you have a b and b paired
this sum it vanishes so in total every
summit gets
d times n minus m
entry c
right so now what happens if your tumblr
is too short
then what happens is that at some point
by the pigeonhole principle we get
something like a z and another z on top
of each other right
yeah right d n minus m if it's less if
it's shorter than d times n minus m so
in total in total every summit gets d
times n minus m entries c
so this one is shorter
than d times n minus m
and rhythm times d
then there has to be by the position
whole principle with some pairing z and
z right
it's just you have oh one column has two
one column has two z's
z is the padding variable
it's the padding variable yes so
pigeonhole principle
says well basically says our columns
vanish
all summons vanish
which is of course
the strongest thing that could happen to
make something zero is all the summers
there's no cancellation it's just all
the summons vanish right hence the
evaluation here vanishes
from this theorem
what is it
oh a block a block is a collection here
of once
that's a block
and this one is a block
and that one is the block here in your
semicircle you have one several times
and two several times and each
collection of ones is a block the
collection of twos is a block the
collection of threes is a block
and in every block you put in your
polynomial
and it just happens that you have too
many z's
so you always have a pairing like that
so direct that's basically follows from
kitchen hall particularly in this
viewpoint which is and the theorem is
rather strong i must say because it
gives you a huge reduction of your
search space for obstructions in
geometric complexity
but it basically says that your
positions almost only
consists of one long first row
okay i'm sorry yeah sure
so in every
evaluation so in the evaluation in the
evaluation which means
evaluation i just did it by example you
evaluate by taking blocks
and putting your polynomial in in every
order inside the blocks
so that was the first block was 1 1 and
you put a b in there but you also put b
a in there and every rearrangement gives
you a sum and if you sum over all these
you put in you put a new polynomial into
the blocks so a this is if this is the
phenomena is a b here
and has
the content is
n and n like like we had always it's n
ones and twos and threes
it's n
and this one has
is a tensor
and when it's a tensor or n
so you can put it exactly into a block
and you can put it into the next block
it has n entries one you put it into the
where the one sit and you put where the
twos
in every reordering
yes
that's neat yeah yes i i very very much
like this now i understand
i i like this theorem yeah
so you can get or so we i had a
reinterpretation of of a proof that we
did
um
which says why it's five minutes is fine
for this i think so it's called even
partitions and practices and it it's
also it says
um
but um but the point now is that you
only need to look at the love
the point of course i mean why is it
interesting this theorem is of course
uh the reason is that the things that
can actually only be obstructions and
geometric complexity theory they they
are not allowed to vanish on these
things because they are not allowed to
finish on the permanent so you cannot
have short first rows because they will
vanish on if you are variant at the
permanent your functions are supposed to
vanish on the determinant but not on the
permanent so the if the row is too short
it's not possible
okay so um
i just want to quickly remark
that you can um
if you study this
doesn't matter you can do this yeah if
say we have this n is even
and lambda
has only
even parts so even rows even rows so
even number of boxes is even then the
pythagorean coefficient is positive
why is that by a variation
so maybe you should mention the history
of this question
but you know it must matter of course
oh this one this yeah
oh yeah that looks like
that's
better than this oh yeah this is like a
conjecture by my toe
20 years ago and there was a partial
resolution of this question by manny
bear
and we started with matthias and peter
um and we got yeah some insights on this
preface and cooperation for that so it
has more and also to pretty deep
understanding of why this is actually
true and how to prove positivity of
paths and coefficients
okay so
okay
it was you should write your quarters
dave on the board
right you're right
i i there's mom
that's okay i mean that's his choice
sorry
these are my core horse and um
is basically the
guy
who taught me all these um
how to look at transfers the right way
so that we can actually um what's
actually also the driving force
in getting this done
so what we can do is now see if lambda
is actually even good
if lambda is even then you can find a
tumble which is really neat so you put
in each you pair your columns into sizes
of two so so they come into in these
flavors right because it's even you can
do that
and so on
um something like that you can
and these are ones
and two so what you write down is you
copy basically whatever is written here
to the next
um column so you gotta get some fitting
that looks like that and now what you do
is you evaluate at a power sum
and gives you basically
the right thing it gives you so at the
power sum of the point is
um so you raise a 1 to the n plus a 2 to
the n
plus and so on plus
say a d to the n
and but the the main point is here
the a i j
the a i say those are
um
real numbers now
if you only take real numbers
say what is the average what does the
evaluation do you plug in to um you plug
into your blocks that are somehow
distributed here but not arbitrarily but
it come in pairs to plug in uh
the a once here i mean you have to
reorder but reordering is not possible
because it's a power sum it's already
symmetric there's no reordering you
replace the a ones by these the ones by
a ones or by a twos doesn't really
matter actually so you place the numbers
by these values
and then you take the product of the
determinants but what happens when you
take the product of the determinants
here is you pick up
the same determinant or always twice so
you pick up the determinant and the
determinant of the same matrix again so
you get a square of after a determinant
of a matrix with only real entries which
is then positive
and you pick up
the same thing here so the same thing
here so you get a product
of positive numbers
and you sum over all those and you sum
up positive numbers only and this is
non-zero so you show by evaluation at
the power sum you show that um
if you evaluate this polynomial at the
power sum you get a non-zero value in
particular this polynomial isn't zero so
the platinum coefficient is
also not
is zero evaluation scheme does it give
some heuristic idea of how often these
precision coefficients vanish for
example i mean on the basis of this
original thing does it give some on the
base of the pictures thing yeah i don't
i don't have a
still don't have it but you know the
experimental thing right well yeah we
are doing experiments of course with
these things
uh the platform coefficient
when there is a zero karnataka
coefficient which we want to have then
it just happens often that also the
platform coefficient is also zero
but sometimes it does not and we have a
list comply that's a compiled list it's
pretty long at 700
that we're actually
we get a positive one here and vanishing
chronicle coefficient but still the
question is open on how to
determine
if this coefficient is positive or not
and we even lack sufficient criteria
something that i mean this is a nice
criterion for proving that coefficient
is actually positive but the
corresponding chronic coefficients
interesting
that are interesting in geometric
complexity theory they always vanish
yeah so that's all my calculations i did
is that these this criterion is not
quite enough
for posit i mean this does not give the
right partitions so we have to refine
that's actually also the project refine
um
these approaches to get more
sophisticated sufficient criteria for
positive letters and coefficients right
this is important to get these criteria
where you can just say well the shape is
like this so it's a positive parallelism
coefficient
because deciding positivity might be too
hard but in all the cases that we
actually calculated
replace the computer proof by some
insight that we have
of i mean from the shape it should
somehow clear that this coefficient is
positive and maybe not in all cases but
maybe in just enough cases so that we
somehow at least
um
in a in a large part can actually have a
non-computer proof of what we have
already computed
that would be nice if we defined
something like that i think that's it
still time for questions
comments
you actually proved something stronger
there because you're proving that this
module occurs in the d c camp variety of
the
veronese
yes or you know which is meaningful if d
is not enormous
oh well that's even better yeah yeah
that's true
i wasn't thinking of that when we did
that yeah but that's yes you're right
now you can yes that's right
yeah the comment you make it's at the
end regarding chronic coefficients so
you said those lambda yes where you now
know the plasticine coefficient is
positive yes
yes
what did you say about the chronic the
chronic coefficient
is
so if you have lambda and two rectangles
in the case
for the three times three determinant so
give it three times d rectangle
in these cases it always happens that
the chronic coefficient is also positive
in these cases
which is related to the paper that we
had with the stretching conduct with the
stretching property so the stretching
factor in these cases seems to be two in
other cases i know it's not two but in
the cases of relevance it seems to be
two
which is unfortunate
so if i understand correctly what's
going on in terms of you know writing
down polynomials of your representative
theory
uh i mean in this case to about due to
this evaluation you're getting a
summation over tableaus yes it's
basically over tuples so you can
interpret this as a summation over
tumblr so the relations here are the
tuple relations still hold even if you
plug in these either a's
and you can explicitly evaluate it if
you go to the determinants of these
vectors but you can also just let it as
variables and say replace the a's by
ones and the b's by twos and just do the
calculation in the space of doubles that
also works because the relations are the
same so the relations of these
determinants here and the double the
russell decorations those are exactly
the same so you can do all this
calculation and this is done
symbolically on just the space of
troubles
but you can you can go to um and do this
numerically if you want or some kind of
field if you want to here because it's
um it's a bit easier
just doing this calculation then um what
you would have to do is you have to
express it in the
basis of semi-standard tables you have
to straighten the tableau which is
sometimes more um just takes more time
actually maybe a lot more time than just
calculating this product of determinants
here
um over some small finite field
so um just depends on what you want to
do if you want to prove that something
vanishes then of course it's important
that you that you use the table approach
if you just want to show non-vanishing
on some point you can just
replace it by this calculation of a
finite field and it's just really fast
great uh well speaking a little more
theoretically um
all right so if you wanted to show that
that this summation is zero yes like one
technique is to show all of the sub the
terms are zero which well yeah that's
one thing yeah restricted grade that's i
think that's almost
the only way that people have used so
far oh no sometimes you have
cancellations very easy cancellations
where you have a lot of summons and you
see a pairing and then uh you have
possibly a negative sum and they all
pair up yeah and then it matches well
that's also a very simple way of seeing
a vanishing and we are still working on
refining these methods it just gets more
and more complicated once you take into
account more of these symmetries and
ways that things can actually cancel it
gets it gets it's really complicated
uh i think i've asked you this before
but so i mean as written it seems like
this is in vnp but i think there's is
this degree issue also still there i
mean
it seems like this is this is okay great
i think this is so it seems okay yes
because it's an exponential sum over
product of determinants
yeah it should be should be okay
yeah should be okay
so how large can you go in the
calculation like in determinant versus
permanent how many
different we cannot
we
did not find anything that is satisfying
for the four times for determining and
even for the three times three
what you can show is that
if you have some um
say some h in
uh in seven three
c7
and this if this is generic
then you have h is not inside gl9 that
three
by finding an obstruction
but this is the only thing that you can
we cannot go to deadpool it's not
working and even even this is not i mean
that we cannot really compare it to the
camera right you cannot really do that
so therefore we are still lacking
information on that i mean you've got
this thing you can't develop that to go
that far i mean it works but there are
so many things that you would have to
test if there's those are actually
obstructions you can you can do things
like this also for that for
it's just it gets hard and also yeah but
also evaluating actually variating at
the determinant
um
you don't want to do that because
um that also gets out of hand quite
quickly
that even that three is in degree
vertically to take 12 or something we
tried to evaluate some polynomial at the
determinant which was important for the
um
so there's this polynomial which defines
the difference between the order and the
old closure we wanted to check
if that's not zero and we we didn't
manage to evaluate it but we have some
ideas on how to
um use the special structure and to make
it faster so that three should be fine
but f4 is completely at the moment is
out of reach to actually do speculations
what do you have if you do naively for
dead three you get up to degree
nine
nineteen you have to give you nine when
you do this yeah
yes yes yes our personal computer degree
knife yes yes you run we run
calculations dv9
which is not
not sufficient of course but you don't
have to of course evaluate at the
permanent you can also say or i make it
easier and project it first to some
smaller thing
but the first things that we find using
chronicle coefficients
uh is the first things that appear to be
so we cannot actually um
degree 10 is the first things that we
find using chronic using for
indeterminate three yes determinant
three is if you compare chronic and
platysma coefficients you look for
obstructions it's degree pretend the
first that occurs it should be quadratic
from one example
i have no idea that's right i know uh
no i haven't i have no idea i have no
idea how it is i mean we have to we have
to make this we have to study these
things i don't know i really don't know
um so but we cannot go very far with
that but i mean nevertheless you can
derive
theoretical results quite quickly with
these right so this is not these are not
very complicated proofs if you use this
approach so we can actually get insights
and um yeah i'm really looking uh in so
we should definitely be able to get more
criteria like like these and and get
more information about positivity of
plasma coefficient because this does not
seem to be the hard problem the heart
problem is that you get a sufficient
criteria that tells you this chronic
coefficient is zero we don't yeah we
don't have that for the platysma
confusion we can write all kinds of
things and and look at the structure of
these doubles and then somehow um don't
have to go over their whole expansion
here but reduce it significantly and
that something is actually positive
that's much easier and also you can
choose points where you want to evaluate
and things like that but the chronicle
coefficient vanishing
is how to prove a way of proving that a
chronic equivalent is zero that is i i
don't know of any way of proving that at
the moment
in our relevant
range right not not contributed
and that would that would be a challenge
other questions
well let's thank christina
a lot of people